I mean terribly awfully I you know I I
in a way I can't help but believe in God
despite all the evidence to the contrary
which makes me very angry at God so I'm
in a way always fighting it but you know
and again two hundred years ago we've
been very easy to be a religious person
and they loved my whole life and now
that and I think would be blissful I
think it's much harder for all of us to
live today you know the world is too
much with us that said and I you know I
don't say that said as much as I say it
as I said it the past half-hour but I'm
saying it that said I think if there is
a God and I think he'd be rather
forgiving of anyone's lack of faith
right now it's you know much easier to
believe in God when you believe the the
Sun goes around the earth and it's flat
and you know the Bible is literal
historical truth it becomes when you
know those things aren't necessarily the
case it becomes harder to believe it in
maybe God chose us now to live now
because our faiths deserve to be tested
a little bit more on
I think that's you know I but
it you know I think God is probably
charitable enough to go well you didn't
believe well why should you
you know I mean I think atheism is
really easy I think it's very easy not
to believe in God I think you know all
that evidence in front of you I think
yeah it's and so I think it's a little
cheap I guess for that reason
I think I guess I didn't come here with
the defense of belief
you know in my back pocket maybe it may
be sheer perversity you know maybe I
believe in God because it seems so
obvious he doesn't exist and I want an
old school but I don't want some sort of
artsy fartsy we're all loved we're all
part of God blabbity blabbity you know
you know I want an Old Testament God I
want a guy throwing Thunderbolts I want
and you know I want punishment I want my
I see no problem with an eye for an eye
I really don't like that's all cool you
know I I don't want tree spirits or
anything or mother goddesses right you
know forget it
dad what's the point of it